we often don't take on big things
because we're so afraid of making
mistakes the reality is anything we do
today is gonna have some issues in the
future but that can't stop us from
getting started let me tell you a secret
ideas don't come out fully formed they
only become clear as you work on them
you just have to get started
the greatest successes come from having
the freedom to fail so what are we
waiting for
today
i want to talk about purpose
but i'm not here to give you the
standard commencement about finding your
purpose we're millennials
we try to do that instinctively instead
i'm here to tell you that finding your
purpose isn't enough the challenge for
our generation is to create a world
where everyone has a sense of purpose
one of my favorite stories is when jfk
went to go visit the nasa space center
and he saw a janitor holding a broom and
he asked him what he was doing and the
janitor replied mr president i'm helping
put a man on the moon purpose is that
feeling that you are a part of something
bigger than yourself that you are needed
and that you have something better ahead
to work for
purpose is what creates true happiness a
change in the world that seems so clear
that you are sure someone else is going
to do it but they're not you will but
it's not enough to have that purpose
yourself you also have to create a sense
of purpose for others and i found that
out the hard way and today i want to
talk about three ways that we can create
a world where everyone has a sense of
purpose by taking on big meaningful
projects together by redefining equality
so everyone has the freedom to pursue
their purpose and by building community
all across the world so first let's take
on big meaningful projects our
generation is going to have to deal with
tens of millions of jobs replaced by
automation like self-driving cars and
trucks but we have the potential to do
so much more than that every generation
has its defining works more than 300 000
people worked to put that man on the
moon including that janitor millions of
volunteers immunized children around the
world against polio and millions of more
people built the hoover dam and other
great projects and now it's our
generation's turn to do great things now
i know maybe you're thinking i don't
know how to build a dam i don't know how
to get a million people involved in
anything well let me tell you a secret
no one does when they begin ideas don't
come out fully formed they only become
clear as you work on them you just have
to get started if i had to know
everything about connecting people
before i got started i never would have
built facebook movies and pop culture
just get this all wrong the idea of a
single eureka moment is a dangerous lie
it makes us feel inadequate because we
feel like we haven't had ours yet and it
prevents people with seeds of good ideas
from ever getting started in the first
place oh and you know what else movies
get wrong about innovation
no one writes math formulas on glass
it's really good to be idealistic
but be prepared to be misunderstood
anyone working on a big vision is going
to get called crazy even if you end up
right anyone taking on a complex problem
is gonna get blamed for not fully
understanding it even though it's
impossible to know everything up front
anyone taking initiative will always get
criticized for moving too fast because
there's always someone who wants to slow
you down in our society we often don't
take on big things because we're so
afraid of making mistakes that we ignore
all the things wrong today if we do
nothing the reality is anything we do
today is going to have some issues in
the future but that can't stop us from
getting started so what are we waiting
for it is time for our generation
defining great works how about stopping
climate change before we destroy the
planet and getting millions of people
involved manufacturing and installing
solar panels how about curing all
diseases and getting people involved by
asking volunteers to share their health
data track their health data and share
their genomes you know today
our society spends more than 50 times as
much treating people who are sick as we
invest in finding cures so people get
sick in the first place
it makes no sense we can fix this and
how about personalizing education so
everyone can learn
these achievements are all within our
reach
let's do them all in a way that gives
everyone in our society a role let's do
big things not just to create progress
but to create purpose
the second is redefining our idea of
equality so everyone has the freedom to
pursue their purpose now many of our
parents had stable jobs throughout their
careers but in our generation we're all
a little entrepreneurial whether we're
starting our own projects or finding our
role in another one and you know that's
great because our culture of
entrepreneurship is how we create so
much progress an entrepreneurial culture
thrives when it is easy to try lots of
new ideas facebook wasn't the first
thing i built i also built chat systems
and games study tools and music players
and i'm not alone jk rowling got
rejected 12 times before she finally
wrote and published harry potter the
greatest successes come from having the
freedom to fail
now today we have a level of wealth and
equality that hurts everyone when you
don't have the freedom to take your idea
and turn it into a historic enterprise
we all lose and right now today our
society is way over indexed on rewarding
people when they're successful and we
don't do nearly enough to make sure that
everyone can take lots of different
shots now let's face it there is
something wrong with our system when i
can leave here and make billions of
dollars in 10 years
while millions of students can't even
afford to pay off their loans let alone
start a business look i know a lot of
entrepreneurs and i don't know a single
person who gave up on starting a
business because they were worried they
might not make enough money but i know
too many people who haven't had the
chance to pursue their dreams because
they didn't have a cushion to fall back
on if they failed we all know you don't
get successful just by having a good
idea or working hard you get successful
by being lucky too if i had to support
my family growing up instead of having
the time to learn how to code if i
didn't know that i was gonna be fine if
facebook didn't work out then i wouldn't
be standing up here today and if we're
honest we all know how much luck we've
had to get to this point in our lives
every generation expands its definition
of equality previous generations fought
for the vote and civil rights they had
the new deal and great society and now
it's time for our generation to define a
new social contract
we should have a society that measures
progress not just by economic metrics
like gdp but by how many of us have a
role we find meaningful we should
explore ideas like universal basic
income to make sure that everyone has a
cushion to try new ideas and we're all
gonna make mistakes so we need a society
that's less focused on locking us up and
stigmatizing us when we do and as our
technology keeps on evolving we need a
society that is more focused on
providing continuous education through
our lives and yes giving everyone the
freedom to pursue purpose isn't going to
be free people like me should pay for it
and a lot of you are gonna do really
well and you should too these are the
values of our whole generation it was
never a question of if we were gonna do
this the only question was when but it's
not just about giving money you can also
give time and i promise you if you just
take an hour to a week that's all it
takes to give someone a hand and help
them reach their potential now maybe
you're thinking that's a lot of time i'm
not sure if i have that much time i used
to think that we can all make time to
give someone a hand let's give everyone
the freedom to pursue purpose not just
because it's the right thing to do but
because when more people can turn their
dreams into something great we are all
better for it purpose doesn't only come
from work the third way we can create a
sense of purpose for everyone is by
building community and in our generation
when we say purpose for everyone we mean
everyone in the world in a recent survey
of millennials around the world asking
what most defines our identity
the most popular answer wasn't
nationality ethnicity or religion it was
citizen of the world that's a big deal
every generation expands the circle of
people we consider one of us and in our
generation that now includes the whole
world we understand that the great arc
of human history bends towards people
coming together in ever greater numbers
from tribes to cities to nations to
achieve things that we could not on our
own we get that our greatest
opportunities are now global we can be
the generation that ends poverty that
ends disease and we get that our
greatest challenges need global
responses too
no country can fight climate change
alone or prevent pandemics progress now
requires coming together not just as
cities or nations but also as a global
community but we live in an unstable
time there are people left behind by
globalization across the whole world and
it's tough to care about people in other
places but we don't first feel good
about our lives here at home there's
pressure to turn inwards and this isn't
going to be decided the u.n either it's
going to happen at the local level when
enough of us
feel a sense of purpose and stability in
our own lives that we can start to open
up and care about everyone else too and
the best way to do that is to start
building local communities right now
change starts local even global change
starts small with people like us
in our generation the struggle of
whether we connect more whether we
achieve our greatest opportunities comes
down to this
your ability to build communities and
create a world where every single person
has a sense of purpose
whenever i face a big challenge that i
sing to my daughter thinking of her
future when i tuck her in at night and
it goes
may the source of strength who's blessed
the ones before us
help us find the courage
to make our lives a blessing
i hope you find the courage to make your
life a blessing